friends of a man killed in a random
shooting are sharing members memories of
that 35 year old they say curtis abraham
was the victim of an attack at a gas
station and police eventually tracked
down the suspect 12 hours later not far
from where the shooting happened and
sasha loftis is at that gas station
tonight with how curtis is being
remembered sasha
denise and brian candles are lit here
outside the convenience store where
friends say curtis abraham lost his life
in that senseless shooting now they're
doing their best to remember the amazing
person they say he was
he brought a certain
aspect to everybody's life of happiness
a longtime friend of curtis abraham
describes what he brought to everyone in
his life he moved out here to get to do
better and he excelled at that dozens
gathered to honor the 35 year old
thursday after quentin adams tells 8
news now curtis was shot and killed when
someone randomly opened fire at this
convenience store in the southwest
valley
the suspect was later arrested after an
hours long search and a barricade
situation we are very thankful for the
public's assistance it is because of the
public's assistance and
outpouring that we were able to put this
case
or solve this case and arrest the
suspect officers say they're glad to
have what they believe is a violent
criminal off the streets but those who
loved curtis say it doesn't change how
quickly he was taken from them you never
know when somebody's going to be gone
tomorrow don't take a text message don't
take a phone call don't take anything
for granted but they know the light he
shined on their world will never be
forgotten it shows you how far one
person can reach and what type of impact
that one person can make on the world
police have not shared the identity of
the suspect in this case but they did
say that a tip led to his arrest they
also added that the suspect's family
cooperated with the investigation
reporting live tonight sasha loftis live
local now